skeletal muscles are voluntary
controlled consciously by the nervous
system
and are made up of fascicles
which are bundles of muscle fibers
surrounded by connective tissue blood
vessels and nerves
motor nerve axons Supply one or more
skeletal muscle fibers constituting a
motor unit
inside a muscle fiber thread-like
structures called myofibrils are
organized into contractile units or
sarcomeres reflecting the striations
characteristic of skeletal muscle
each sarcomere is made up of thick and
thin myofilaments
strands of proteins called myosin and
actin
myosin forms thick filaments actin forms
thin filaments
the protruding heads of myosin filaments
form cross bridges that bind to actin
filaments and ATP an energy transport
molecule
thin filaments contain a sequence of
actin molecules with myosin binding
sites
at rest actin molecules bind tropomyosin
and troponin two contractile proteins
that inhibit contraction
skeletal muscle contraction begins at
the muscle fibers plasma membrane or
sarcolemma
with invaginations called transverse or
t tubules
that surround each myofibril
and open to the extracellular space
t-tubules connect to a membranous
network called the sarcoplasmic
reticulum
that store calcium and transfer ions via
voltage-gated channels
into the myofibril sarcoplasm to
regulate muscle contraction
in the first step of muscle contraction
called excitation a motor nerve fires an
Impulse or action potential across the
neuromuscular Junction depolarizing the
sarcolemma and generating an action
potential
that spreads through the sarcolemma
into the T tubules and excites the
muscle fiber
the second step is coupling wherein the
action potential
depolarizes the T tubules
channels in the sarcoplasmic reticulum
release calcium into the sarcoplasm
along the myofilaments troponin binds
calcium and separates from tropomyosin
in the third step called contraction
tropomyosin shifts away from actin to
expose the myosin binding sites enabling
myosin to bind to actin resulting in the
activation of ATP and the cross Bridges
released energy causes the myosin heads
to rotate and pull the thin filaments
inward sliding past the thick filaments
and shortening the sarcomere
the fourth step of muscle contraction is
relaxation in which calcium ions return
to the sarcoplasmic reticulum and break
the myosin actin bonds the cross Bridges
disengage and the sarcomere lengthens
resulting in relaxation of the muscle
and the end of the contraction
[Music]